a key question in the Trump Russia
collusion story is how involved was
Vladimir Putin how in the know was
Vladimir Putin and a new report from The
Washington Post which has been just
crushing it when it comes to trump
Russia says that Vladimir Putin gave
direct orders to help elect Donald Trump
. reportedly president obama received a
secret CIA report back in August of 2016
that report quote captured Putin
specific instructions on the operations
audacious objectives defeat or at least
damaged the Democratic nominee Hillary
Clinton this is stunning but it's not
totally surprising right I mean this
builds on there was a previous CBS news
report which said that US intelligence
officials knew that Vladimir Putin had
approved the operation but it didn't go
any further this is one more step which
is Vladimir Putin was giving direct
instructions as to the carrying out of
this attempt to get Trump elected and
this is important right the degree of
Vladimir Putin's involvement is
important but it also doesn't change how
bad whatever Trump's whatever Trump's
associates or Trump himself did might be
it's interesting to know how involved
Putin was it is relevant to know how
involved Putin was but it doesn't affect
potential violations or charges or
wrongdoing by Donald Trump and his team
and I also want to be upfront about
something else here because Pat I want
the truth right if there's no collusion
I want to know that there's no collusion
if there's no impropriety great let's
find out about that and be done with it
it is possible that Vladimir Putin was
directly trying to help Donald Trump and
Donald Trump truly didn't know or at
minimum wasn't involved and I'll explain
why was Vladimir Putin want Donald Trump
to be President of the United States
Putin wants the weakest dumbest most
manipulable person to win given that
that's why Putin would want Donald Trump
in the Oval Office it is possible that
Russia acted independently of Trump to
try to get him elected just because
Vladimir Putin might have wanted to help
Trump doesn't necessarily mean that
Donald Trump was in on it or conspiring
it means Putin sawed Trump is weak easy
to manipulate and decided to act I think
the more likely scenario is that many of
the people in Trump's orbit or Trump
circles were involved or at least knew
what was happening with Russia and let
it happen they may have even insulated
Trump from it so when we hear Donald
Trump genuinely say there was no
collusion I had nothing to do this is
all silly Trump really might believe
that because his campaign might have
kept them insulated from possible ties
to Russia and I don't think it's
particularly surprising to that Putin
directly ordered this because you really
have a contrast of governing styles here
yeah you know Putin's going to be much
more hands-on not something
uncharacteristic of a totalitarian
regime
yeah but then Trump is one to delegate
out responsibility you got to go speak
to Steve Bannon or Jared Kushner so when
you have those two contrasting elements
there I could see how Trump could be so
easily manipulated it's absolutely
possible and it's also possible Trump
was involved in he's just lying we will
hopefully find out and I want to remind
you of something I've talked about
before there's this book called
foundations of geopolitics that's really
big in Russian political circles and
intelligence circles and it's basically
the plan for how can Russia exert more
dominance over geopolitics and in Europe
part of the strategy from the book is
you push the UK to isolate from the rest
of Europe you push Germany as the leader
in the region you try to encourage
alliances that are to your advantage
between European nations and then within
the United States here's a summary of
the foundations of geopolitics approach
Russia should use its special services
within the borders of the US to fuel
instability and separatism
for instance promote african-american
racists Russia should introduce
geopolitical disorder into internal
American activity encouraging separatism
and ethnic social and racial conflicts
actively supporting dissident movements
whether they be extremist racist or
sectarian groups and try to destabilize
the internal political processes
of the US what's going on right now
within the US a political system
Trump's administration is at an
affective standstill due to constantly
dealing with scandal after scandal after
scandal the u.s. is increasingly
isolated from the European Union due to
Trump's bizarre and clueless
declarations about everything ranging
from NATO to who knows what else
involving Europe and brexit and blah
blah blah blah blah we don't yet know
the extent of possible collusion
recordin ation but the end result of
what's happening in the context of
alleged Russian interference is exactly
what is described in this Russian
geopolitical favorite book foundations
of geopolitics yeah it's definitely not
as straightforward as say Trump being
Putin's puppet or you know Putin's going
to attack Utah or something like that
they meddled in the election for
influence over the candidate that was
going to take office and now you see
things like the Trump administration
trying to pull off sanctions from Russia
and this is why you know I call this the
political CSI effect we we know that
juries have been significantly
influenced by programs like CSI where
they go in and they expect to see an
open-and-shut definitive DNA case that
will prove someone as a murderer or
something like that and the reality is
very very few murder cases actually have
the degree of evidence that you see
presented or conjured up in these TV
shows like CSI along the same lines
analogously there are definitely people
who are only going to say you know what
I guess there was some collusion here if
you catch Trump and Putin on video
literally and specifically planning
every aspect of the thing and
unfortunately that's not how smart and
effective political operatives like
Vladimir Putin work and it's unlikely
that we would ever see that and I think
that the standard which some trumpets
and really people all over the political
spectrum are expecting we're never
really going to see that and it's sort
of CSI effect in politics yeah it's
interesting that you bring up that CSI
murder mystery analogy because even
fingerprints are considered
evidence right and when it comes to the
Trump Russia scandal we certainly have
circumstantial evidence we don't have
any sight of direct evidence at this
point we've got the answer enough to
convict someone we have the political
equivalent of fingerprints
don't wait sure that's for sure send me
your thoughts about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman follow the show on Twitter
at David Pakman show a lot of people
trolling me on there lately but still
good good discussion I like it when fans
send me thoughts about the show the
trolling I can do without it but in any
case you can follow me on Twitter at D
Pakman